parte de lo máximo que puede soportar la
tubería antes de desbordarse son 50 pies
cúbicos de agua para t mayor que 8 el
agua de lluvia se mantiene entrando y
saliendo de la tubería con las mismas
tasas iniciales hasta que el agua
empieza a desbordarse
escribe pero no resuelva una ecuación
para obtener el tiempo w en donde la
tubería empieza a desbordarse esta
ecuación debe involucrar una o más
integrales muy bien entonces la tubería
empieza a desbordarse y nos dicen que
empieza a desbordarse en el tiempo doble
1 y también nos dicen que la tubería va
a empezar a desbordarse cuando tenga más
de 50 pies cúbicos de agua porque dice
lo máximo que puede soportar la tubería
antes de desbordarse son 50 pies cúbicos
de agua entonces podemos averiguar para
qué tiempo la tubería va a tener 50 pies
cúbicos de agua en ella así que para
esto podemos tomar la función amp que
definimos en el vídeo pasado la función
up del inciso anterior y ahora vamos a
sustituir a t por el tiempo en donde se
desborda el agua de la tubería
es w es decir nos vamos a aplicar en
cuanto es am de este tiempo w y bueno
nosotros sabemos que a de w
es lo mismo que 50 pies cúbicos de agua
porque este es el tiempo en donde la
tubería empieza a desbordarse y bueno la
tubería empieza a desbordarse cuando
tenemos 50 pies cúbicos de agua así que
con esta ecuación que tengo aquí ya
solamente tendríamos que resolver para w
y dice escriben pero no resuelvas así
que podemos hacer más claro y además nos
va a ayudar a involucrar una o más
integrales para eso recordemos que a de
w
lo tenemos justo aquí es lo mismo que 30
30 más la integral de 0 a w en este caso
vamos a sustituir el valor de t por w
de bueno de rd y en lugar de poner x
como ya no necesito ate en esta ecuación
voy a poner mejor r de t para que sea
más claro y así no metemos a x en mi
respuesta
entonces me quedaría 30 más la integral
de 0 w
de rd t
- del dt
muy bien y todo esto lo vamos a
multiplicar por d
muy bien así que esta es la cantidad
total de agua en el tiempo de w y bueno
sabemos que esto es igual a 50 pies
cúbicos
entonces ya están escribe pero no
resueltas una ecuación para obtener el
tiempo w
el tiempo w en donde la tubería empieza
a desbordarse esta ecuación debe
involucrar una o más integrales y esta
tenemos de aquí la respuesta correcta
así que si resolvemos para w tendríamos
el tiempo en donde la tubería empezaría
a desbordarse claro suponiendo que
cuando llegues a 50 pies cúbicos no va a
disminuir la cantidad de agua así que
cruzando este tiempo w
pasaremos de los 50 pies cúbicos de agua
e inclusive puedes intentarlo por tu
cuenta
dar un valor mayor a w después de
resolver esta ecuación que tengo aquí y
así vas a comprobar que tienes más
cantidad de agua que entra que es la que
sale en ese tiempo
en ese tiempo en ese tiempo mayor que w
tendrías que r de ese tiempo sería mayor
que te de ese tiempo lo que quiere decir
que la cantidad de agua crece y por lo
tanto pasamos de estos 50 pies cúbicos
de agua después de ese tiempo y bueno si
quieres obtener a w
lo único que tienes que hacer es
resolver todo esto ahora hay otra opción
de llegar a esta misma respuesta
correcta lo que se me ocurre es lo
siguiente pensar un poco en lo que
resolvimos en el problema pasado en el
problema pasado vimos que cuando el
tiempo tomaba el valor de 8 a de 8 era
lo mismo que 48.54 4
entonces como este tiempo es mayor que 8
podemos escribir la respuesta de la
siguiente manera vamos a decir que ahora
vamos a usar la siguiente integral
voy a poner que la cantidad de agua en
el tiempo
t igual a 8
48.54 4 esta es una muy buena
aproximación y a esto le vamos a sumar
bueno la cantidad de agua que se tiene
desde tim igual a 8 hasta t igual a
doble
de quién bueno de mi función de dtm
a esto le quitamos la función de dtm ok
y todo esto multiplicado por de t y
bueno ya sabemos que esto tiene que ser
igual a 50 pies cúbicos así que ya está
esta es otra respuesta correcta de hecho
cualquiera de estas dos respuestas te
llevarían a un resultado correcto y
siete preguntas para que w
tenemos 50 pies públicos de agua bueno
pues tendremos que resolver cualquiera
de estas dos ecuaciones que tengo aquí y
después de que obtenemos a doble un
puedes probar que en esa w
tienes una tasa de cambio creciente o lo
puedes pensar como una entrada neta
positiva en ese punto lo cual que
estaría diciendo que en ese punto el
agua se empieza